land o lakes is a customer who collects  massive amounts of data from farmers  soil type rainfall fertilizer amounts  seed type things like that but they  didn't have a way to bring that data  together to gain insight from it we were  able to over a very short amount of time  write an application for them that  pulled that data into bigquery using  Google cloud platform and so by doing  that across millions of acres of  farmland farmers are being able to grow  more food with less input less resources  which is super important for companies  who are looking to be more efficient in  the amount of resources that they use to  grow food and it also helps them over  time increase their caulfield to feed  our growing population